a texas child protective services
employee
was just caught on camera telling a 14
year old girl in foster care to become a
prostitute
child protective services fires an
employee caught on camera telling a 14
year old girl in foster care to be a
prostitute but that state agency said
nothing about the video's existence
during a recent
fox 26's randy wallace joins us live
from downtown with that exclusive randy
[Applause]
yes sherman you would think the judge
overseeing the 14 year old girl's
custody case would need to know about
the cell phone video but apparently cps
didn't think so
she's a mother of nine
and she does have a daughter who has had
some behavioral problems that's why
kesha basley turned to child protective
services but then her 14 year old
daughter told her when she told a cps
employee she was hungry that worker told
her to become a prostitute the daughter
recorded the cps worker on her cell
phone
if you gonna be a hoe be a real hoe so
says the child protective services
employee thankfully the cps employee has
been fired
horrible story why do i even bring it up
on the show yeah terrible things happen
in foster care terrible things happen in
these bureaucratic agencies especially
cps so that's not exactly a man bites
dog story the reason i bring it up on
this show
is i gotta ask i sometimes
ask this question when you see a really
outrageous story
and we all know it's so wrong but i
asked this question because of all the
confusion in our culture why is this
wrong
why is it wrong why is it wrong
that the child protective services
employee told the 14 year old girl
to be a hoe
and to
make a lot of money
selling her body for for sex
why is it wrong
we are told in our culture that sex work
is real work
we are told in our culture that
prostitution really should be legalized
people should be able to do whatever
they want with their bodies people own
their bodies and they have a right to do
with their bodies whatever they so
please we're told this by the people on
the left we're even told by a lot of the
people on the right especially the
people who who
ascribe to a kind of extreme
libertarianism and who worship at the
altar of the free market
why should you not have the right to
sell your body for sex
even a lot of people on the right who
say look you know i'm conservative but
you know people want to do whatever with
their body that's not my business
so there's no according to
probably most people in the country at
least if you were to ask them about
their their conscious ideology they'd
say yeah there's nothing really wrong
with prostitution but they'd say there's
a problem because this is a kid
yeah okay
yeah it's a kid i know that's wrong but
the libs don't think that the libs
believe not only should kids be able to
engage in sexual activity and they
encourage sexual activity among kids
and not just even the radical pro
pedophilia normalize the minor attracted
person maps lunatics
but everyone who suggests we give
condoms to
minors that we give we put minors on
birth control young teenagers in many
cases they are encouraging sexual
activity among little kids but forget
about that for a second
we've got now got
the mainstream democrats up to and
including the white house
encouraging kids not just to have sexual
activity and consent to sexual activity
but to consent to permanent sexual
activity through transgenderism
not just a one-night stand not just be a
real hoe at the local motel we're saying
and the white house is saying little
girls minors can consent to having their
wombs cut out
that that
little boys and little girls can consent
to being put on cross-sex hormones
making permanent sexual decisions that
could sterilize them a hell of a lot
more significant hell of a lot more
traumatic than a one-night stand or be a
real hoe much more significant than
whatever the cps employee is saying so
what's wrong with this
the reason it's wrong
is because all those premises are wrong
because you don't have a right to do
whatever you want with your body because
there is no right to prostitution
because some sexual behaviors are
obviously wrong even if it's between
consenting people and because kids can't
give consent
and because
we need to protect kids and and make
proper decisions on their behalf and
those decisions need to be based on an
objective moral order not the crazy
sexual fantasies of the left that's why
it's all wrong
and we should be able to use this wisdom
we know
that this stuff is wrong
there's so many things in society we
look at it we just say uh gosh i know
that's wrong it's called the wisdom of
repugnance and then we just convince
ourselves it's okay
we allow ideology to convince us that
our intuitions are wrong our intuitions
are prejudice
the true prejudice meaning are just
natural judgments that we have of all
sorts of terrible things those are good
those are reliable those we should we
should generally defer to those we
should examine them but we should defer
to those in a lot of cases inherited
wisdom tradition
those are good things those are the
conservative insights okay that's what
we've got to rely on
if we throw that out the window we give
the culture to the libs right now go to
goodranchers.com
knowles
regardless of what the biden
administration defines as a recession
americans are worried they're feeling it
food and gas prices are higher than i've
ever seen in my lifetime that is why i
am so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers good ranchers offers an
inflation-proof subscription model that
lets you lock in your price the day you
subscribe i don't know how this works i
hope good ranchers can stay in business
this is such a good deal
you you subscribe right now you can
either buy a box of meat
absolutely top quality meat you just buy
a one-off box and you enjoy it or you
can subscribe and for the whole life of
your subscription it will never go up
do it right now this is the most insane
deal i've ever seen goodranchers.com
knowles use code knolls at checkout you
get 30 bucks off plus free shipping lock
in that price recession proof your meals
for life inflation proof your meals for
life you'll be automatically entered to
win 30 minutes by the way of all access
with me on september 30th if you do that
this offer ends august 31st we're
calling it a meet and greet go to
goodranchers.com and all use code
knowles at checkout
i'm glad you like that clip now whoop
hold up yeah we got a million subscribe
we have over a million subscribers now
that's great it's not good enough we got
to keep pushing
we need a billion subscribers
we're only going to do that if you ring
that bell right now
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you